hi I'm BD Wong I'm here at BuzzFeed
and I'm here to read your thirst tweets
I'm really skeptical about this I really
don't know what is in this container so
I'm a little bit prepared to be kind of
humiliated by the lack of thirst okay
look I have a BD Wong problem sometimes
I wake in the middle of the night
envisioning his lips wrapped around that
chicken wing shrug and this refers to of
course my famous chicken wing video that
you can see on YouTube and I guess
there's something kind of like salacious
about the way I ate the chicken wing but
you know don't go and look right now we
will war what while we're doing this
okay that's that
do you want and punch me in the face and
I thank him and pretty one with say
you're welcome because you see there's
no picture of this person so I don't
know whether I would have an inclination
to punch them or not
that's important I'm going to make and
only fans where it's just me reviewing
sexy pictures of beauty wall that's very
nice I'm convinced that BD Wong stands
for Big Daddy Wong see now that's a
disappointment I know it does not oh
here we go see sit wait wait wait is BD
Wong full name
big dick Wong BD Wong owns my app that's
really great I'm really proud of that I
really like that I'm hoping that it's a
kind of a that goes with a night space
but this looks like a picture of Johnny
ham which would be all right
BD Wong please be my sugar daddy I am a
simple boy with simple tastes picture of
a baby actually please be my sugar daddy
meaning I have to pay for everything I
am a simple boy with simple tastes
meaning you won't have to pay for that
much yeah we don't cheap people get
treated cheaply please
split my bussy in half please
exclamation point exclamation point
explains more high school nation point
at the nation point I'm begging
I just like the bore witness of it and
the explicitness of it I just wanted
explicit thirst tweets and I finally got
one that's really good and this is a
picture of what looks like George
Carlin's either George Carlin or ET pop
lock and drop my BD Wong okay like that
I'll do that
I would like BD Wong to spit in my mouth
stomp on my neck choke me with his
thighs and then tuck me into bed honey
is that you
Beauty Wong suck my toes well I I need
to see some tow JPEGs before I will
consent to that just learn Beauty
Wallace 58 years old and I feel like a
decrepit hag he is the ultimate daddy
how thirsty are you I think I feel more
self-conscious about the fact that
there's a lot of people in this room
watching me do this then then the fact
that I'm actually doing it you know
reading your thirst tweets is not
something that is a concept that's
foreign to me I mean I go on Twitter all
the time you know like the president
sitting on the toilet
looking at my Twitter looking for
validation but I don't know it's because
it's being called out for for for doing
something that I would normally do
anyway it's a this is beating Wong and
I'm officially no longer a thirst tweet
virgin but please watch aquafina is Nora
from Queens on Comedy Central on
Wednesday nights of 10:30 Eastern
Standard Time
[Music]
[Music]
you